joining us now with reaction fox news
contributors joe concha leo 2.0 terrell
i think all three of us are on record i
predicted a two-point win in virginia
leo i predicted a win
you did i predicted
leo go ahead
no i put it out on twitter an hour ago
it's over he won virginia glenn young
congratulations okay they still got it
counted it's 80 percent of the votes
but it's 53
yunkan has maintained a strong lead
throughout the whole night i'll be
honest uh joe concha
i thought the fox poll was an outlier
poll i might be proven wrong
i i looked at the internals and it was
an eight-point race and i said this this
just doesn't fit with every other poll
that i'm reading
and and if they're right and i'm wrong i
will humbly apologize
and the fox poll a week ago had younken
winning by about this margin eight
points so it looks like terry mcauliffe
is running out of runway at this point
with 80 percent counted as you said but
sean we are witnessing a political
earthquake tonight straight out of the
san andreas fault if that fault was on
the east coast and by the way the
lincoln project along with bill crystal
who plays a conservative on twitter they
endorsed terry mcauliffe and as usual
they lost again as they always do with
every state race those and i'll say this
generously scumbags
who concocted a white nationalist hoax
against glenn younkin in the most
pathetic in that political stunt we've
seen in modern politics only help seal
mcauliffe's fate so that's really that
that's very delicious you could go in
front of your home right now and burn
money in the street before donating to
those clowns or listen to bill crystal
but in virginia as you've mentioned
mcauliffe tried to run against donald
trump instead of junking in this race
the former governor even brought in joe
biden who brought trump 24 times in one
relatively short speech this last week
and that's what happens when you have
nothing to run on especially education
now we're seeing in new jersey where i
am jack citarelli up here a little bit
in this state and even if phil murphy
somehow pulls this out and wins a close
one joe biden won this state by 16
points a year ago the president's
coattails are non-existent he is toxic
it will be a red tsunami in 2022. nancy
pelosi will be retired as house speaker
after gop takes that chamber congress
and say hello to cocaine mitch mcconnell
as your senate majority leader again and
look just 36 percent of democrats say
they want joe biden to be their nominee
in 2024. and kamala harris that's your
plan b you have to wonder if the
democratic party with no real bench who
could they run if the ticket right now
in biden and harris isn't your answer
stacey abrams marianne williamson bernie
again mayor pete i mean this is going to
have ramifications the virginia result
and a possible new jersey result for
weeks months even years to come because
this shows you where joe biden is at
this point in the eyes of the american
people sean i agree with that too and i
don't think enough people are gonna the
white house is already doing everything
they can do to distance themselves from
this disaster but i don't think uh joe
biden helped anybody just look at the
border look at afghanistan look at the
begging opec energy prices heating
prices the prices of goods and services
supply chain issues uh leo we'll give
you the last word this segment
i'll be very simple listen the race card
is dead at the last minute out of
desperation mccullough tried to use the
race car and i want to make sure this is
clear bait try to use a race car this
was about education this was about
parents rights and the race car is no
longer applicable and i would suggest to
the democrats they need to go back to
the drawing board because people like
myself have left the democratic party
because when they don't have ideas when
they don't play with facts they throw up
the race car and that is a surrender
sign when they use the race card it's a
surrender because they have no facts
they have no argument they're trying to
get you to be divisive and the people of
virginia and hopefully the people in new
jersey have spoken that we do not we
reject the race card we want issues
involving our kids we want we do not
want critical race theory we want to
have people govern us and give us our
liberty and freedom and that's what you
see in virginia right now
all right thank you leo terrell